let's say I'm walking along some trail
and there are some trees on the side of
the road and these are let's just say
these are some plants and these are the
these are the Bark's of the trees maybe
I should do it in brown but you get the
idea these are some plants that are
along the side of the road or at least
the stem of the plant or the bark of the
tree and in the background I have some
mountains maybe those mountains are
several miles away so then I have some
mountains in the background we know just
from experience that if I'm walking
let me draw myself over here we know
that we know that if I'm walking this
way the trees look like they're going
past me much faster much faster than the
mountains like I'll just going past one
tree after another and they'll just
whizz past me maybe if I'm running but
the mountains don't seem to be moving
that quickly and this idea that as you
[ __ ] as you change your position the
things that are closer to you seem to be
moved more the things that are further
from you this idea or this I guess this
property is called parallax parallax and
what we're going to do in this video and
maybe it's especially obvious if you're
driving in a car then things close to
your whizzing by you
maybe the curb of the street or whatever
while the things that are further away
don't seem to be whizzing by you as fast
what I want to do in this video is think
about how we can use parallax to figure
out how far certain stars are and what I
want to emphasize is that this method is
only good for relatively close stars
we don't have instruments sensitive
enough yet to use parallax to measure
stars that are really really really far
away but to think about how this is done
how we use stellar parallax
so let me write stellar up here how we
use stellar parallax the parallax of
stars to figure out how far away they
are let's think a little bit about our
solar system so here is our Sun in the
solar system and here is Earth at one
point in the year and I what I want to
do is and let's just say this is the
North Pole kind of popping out of the
screen here and so the earth is rotating
it's rotating in that direction and I
also want to think about a star that is
obviously outside of our solar system
and I'm really under estimating the
distance to this star
we'll see or as you might already know
the distance to the nearest star from
our solar system is 250,000 times the
distance between the Earth and the Sun
so if I wanted to draw this to scale
well first of all the earth would be
this unnoticeable dot here but you would
also whatever distance this is you would
have to multiply that by 250,000 to get
the distance to this nearest star anyway
with that said let's think about what
that star would look like from the
surface of the earth so let me pick a
point on the surface maybe if we're
thinking about North America or right
there in the northern hemisphere so
let's take that little patch of land and
think about how the position of that
star would look so that's the patch of
land maybe this is my house right over
here jutting out the side of the earth
maybe this is me standing I'm drawing
everything sideways because I'm trying
to hold this perspective so this is me
looking up and let's say at this point
in time where the way I've drawn this
patch the Sun will just be coming over
the horizon so the Sun this is
essentially at sunrise so let me do my
best at drawing the Sun from my point of
view it looks like remember the earth is
rotating in this way is rotating it's
rotating the way I've drawn it it's
rotating it counterclockwise but from
the surface of the earth it would look
like the Sun is coming up here it's
rising in the east but right at that
bright at that dawn on this day when the
earth is right over here
what would that star look like well the
star so if we look at this version of
the earth if you look at this version of
the earth the star is kind of skewed a
little bit not straight up straight up
would be this direction from the point
of view of my house it is now skewed a
little bit closer to the Sun so if you
go in this zoomed-in version straight up
would look something like that and maybe
based on my measurement it would look
like the star it would look like the
star is it would look like the star is
right over there so it's a little bit
skewed towards where the Sun is rising
towards the east relative to straight up
now let's fast forward six months so
that the earth is on the
side of its orbit from the Sun so let's
fast forward six month six months
we're over here and let's wait for a
time of day where we are essentially the
that little patch of the earth is
pointed in the same direction in at
least in our galaxy maybe so let's so
it's pointing in the same direction and
if you think about it if we go back to
this patch of Earth now the Sun the
earth is still rotating in that
direction but now the Sun is on the west
the Sun is going to be right over here
maybe I'll do it like this just to make
it clear I'll draw this side of the Sun
with this greenish color obviously the
Sun is not green but it'll make clear
that now we're talking about the Sun is
going to be over here
the Sun is going to be over here the
patch is going to be turning away from
the Sun so it looked to that observer on
earth like the Sun is setting so it look
like the Sun is going down over the
horizon but the important thing is once
we're at this point in the year what
will that star look like well we if we
have this large diagram we see that the
star is now the star is now it's now
relative to straight up it is now a
little bit a little bit to the west now
a little bit more on the side of that
Setting Sun so the star would now look
the star would now look like it is right
there and if we have good enough if we
have good enough instruments we can
measure the angle between where the Sun
where that star was six months ago and
where it is now and let's call that
angle well I'll call that angle two
times theta
and the reason why I call it two times
theta we could call that angle relative
we could call theta the angle relative
or the angle between the star and being
straight up so this would be theta and
that would be theta and I care about
that because if I know theta we can and
if I know the distance from the earth to
the Sun I can then use a little bit of
trigonometry to figure out the distance
to that star because if you think about
it this theta right over here is the
same as this angle so if this is
straight up that is looking straight up
into the night sky this would be the
angle theta if you know that angle from
basic
trigonometry or actually even basic
geometry if you say this is a right
angle over here this would be 90 this
would be 90 minus theta and then you
could use some basic trigonometry if you
know this distance if you know this
distance right here and you're trying to
figure out this distance the distance to
that nearest star so this is what we're
trying to figure out well we could say
look we need a trigonometric function
that deals with the opposite angle the
opposite angle of what we know we know
this thing right over here and the
adjacent angle we already know this
thing right over here so let me call
this let me call this the earth-sun
distance or let me say let me just call
this let me just call this D and we want
to figure out X so some basic
trigonometry and I know you might want
to do this if you forget the basic
trigonometric functions so Toa sine is
opposite over hypotenuse cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse tangent is
opposite over adjacent so the tangent
function deals with the two sides of
this right triangle that we can now deal
with so we could say that the tangent
tangent of 90 of 90 minus theta this
angle right over here so this angle
right over here tangent of that angle
right over there let me write it tangent
of 90 minus theta
that angle right over there is equal to
the opposite side is equal to x over the
adjacent side over D or another way if
you assume that we know the distance to
the Sun you multiply both sides times
that distance you get D times the
tangent of 90 minus theta is equal to X
and you can figure out and you can
figure out the distance from our solar
system to that star now I want to make
it very very very clear these are huge
distances I did not draw this to scale
the the distance to the nearest star is
actually 250,000 times the distance to
our Sun so this angle is going to be
super super super super small so you
need to have
very good instruments even to measure
even to observe the stellar parallax to
the nearest stars and we're constantly
launching or having better instruments
and actually the Europeans right now are
in the process of a mission called Gaia
to measure these to enough accuracy that
we can start to measure the accurate
distance to stars several tens of
thousands of light-years away so that
will start to give us a very accurate
map of a significant chunk of our galaxy
which is about a hundred thousand
light-years in diameter